[Música]
y hoy en nuestra sección directo a nos
vamos hasta chile para hablar con
nuestra corresponsal en Santiago
Patricia Luna sobre la presidencia
provisional de la alianza del Pacífico
esto luego que México se negara a
entregar el liderazgo del bloque a Perú
tras la destitución del presidente Pedro
Castillo el gobierno peruano recibirá
finalmente el primero de agosto de manos
chilenas esta presidencia Patricia
Buenas noches qué argumentos daba México
para negarse a entregar la presidencia Y
qué han dicho desde chile al respecto
Buenas noches Rodrigo chile se ofrece
así como intermediario para dar salida a
esta crisis diplomática que desde hace
meses se enfrenta a México con Perú y
que también ha salpicado a la alianza
del Pacífico por qué Porque la
presidencia Pro tempore que en este
momento ostenta México debía de ser
entregada a finales de diciembre o
comienzos de 2023 a Perú sin embargo
Manuel López Obrador especificó que no
podía entregar esta presidencia a un
gobierno espurio y usurpador porque
sería como legitimar un golpe de estado
eso entender lo que la destitución del
presidente Castillo se debió a las
élites del país que actúan como élites
conservadoras racistas clasistas y muy
corruptas muy similares a las de México
chile se ofrece ahora como un
intermediario reconoce siempre que la
presidencia Pro tempore pertenecía a
Perú y trata así de dar salida Durante
este mes que ostentará esta presidencia
para trasladarla luego comienzos de
agosto en este mes el canciller chileno
especificó que se van a activar mesas
técnicas en materias como género
Comercio en mercado digital economía
pequeñas y medianas empresas y también
alianzas internacionales de la alianza
del Pacífico bueno Patricia y
probablemente del espectadores que no
sepan bien que es esta Alianza del
Pacífico que se ha convertido en uno de
los principales organismos de
integración en la región así que
cuéntanos qué es
es un organismo de integración económica
y de negocios comercial formada por
cuatro países México Colombia Perú y
chile que comenzó se acordó en 2011
comenzó a funcionar en julio de 2015 y
el protocolo comercial en 2016 y hay que
estar muy atento a las cifras entre los
cuatro países representan más de 225
millones de personas en la región es
también entre el 37 y el 40% del
producto interior bruto de la región y
también concentran el mercado exterior
aproximadamente un 52% y un 45% de la
inversión extranjera ha conseguido a lo
largo de estos años se reconocida
internacionalmente por lograr acuerdos
que permiten vistas de turismo a las
personas vistas de estudiantes
el flujo de bienes personas servicios y
también acuerdos de desgravamenes entre
los comercio el comercio
intrarregional entre muchos otros logros